I think the political situation always
had a huge effect on on what is humorous
or what's funny what people are laughing
at you know and then in when the
situation's bad people need that escape
when our leadership is poor you need
that satire not just as a release but
also as you know as the strong finger of
the people pointing back there's nothing
more there's no tool there's no
punishment worse than being laughed at
and there's nothing our leaders hate
more than being mocked that's any leader
across the board nobody likes it you
don't like being locked you know so that
the most effective tool we have as
people is being able to laugh at our
bosses so when our bosses are especially
oppressive that's when that kind of
humor comes to the forefront now I mean
right now I think we're in an extremely
difficult political situation i'm glad
i'm not at the daily show anymore for
instance a guy was there during the Bush
administration like there was plenty to
laugh at you know in those days in every
every American administration has plenty
of laughs at but and this is going to
feel dated I'm sure a year from now or
10 years from now or you know whatever
but but where we stand in the middle of
februari in 2017 there's always a
temptation in comedy to go for the
low-hanging fruit to go for the easy
jokes you know and it's right now it's
not even that the fruit is low-hanging
it's on the ground it's rotting on the
ground like you don't need a comedian to
say to pick this up and look at this
fruit you know examine this this is why
this fruit is funny anyone anyone
walking up can you point down at this
joke on the ground and go oh my god what
the hell is going on you know uh you
know a lot of the brilliance of Jon
Stewart or Trevor Noah is is finding
this Apple and going but you've probably
seen this Apple a hundred times you know
you don't haven't thought anything of it
look at this Apple really look at it
when you examine it you realize i'll tak
a crazy goddamn apple you know but
anyone can see you know the drop
applesauce is an apple tree you have
pineapple falling off the tree
coconuts falling off the tree up you'll
frog falling off the tree it's so
intrinsically bizarre that there's
almost not a challenge for a writer a
comedian to make fun of it and invite
and I'm not even being part of in here
i'm not even talking like I do think
administration is doing some crazy stuff
but i also think like our country is so
divided right now that we're hearing
crazy stuff from the other side to like
I feel like it's and I don't get I made
about a false equivalence I'm not going
to take it but I just think like there's
too much it is everything to the
forefront there's no subtlety anymore
you don't need a brilliant comedic mind
to define the comedy and things your
grandmother can go on Twitter and say
that's fucking ridiculous and she's
right and she's just as funny as your
brilliant friend you know who spent 20
years studying this at the University
Southern California so
[Music]